الاحد الثاني والعشرين من يناير بدايه
السنه القمريه الجديده او مهرجان الربيع
بالصين تستمر الاحتفالات على مدار 16 يوما
وتختتم بمهرجان الفوانيس الذي ينتهي في
الخامس من فبراير موعد الاحتفالات يختلف
من عامل لاخر لكنها تقع عاده بين اواخر
يناير ومنتصف فبراير العام الحالي وفقا
للتقويم الصيني هو
4.721 تكتسي المدن في الصين بالاشكال
والرموز والالوان وتتخذ شكل الارنب بما ان
العام الحالي هو عام الارنب والثاني
الابراج الصينيه وتحتفل به دول اسيويه
اخرى مثل اندونيسيا فيتنام كوريا الجنوبيه
ماليزيا ودول الغربيه ايضا ثقافه صينيه
تمثل الارانب بالقمر لان ظل القمر يشبه
الارنب بحسب تفسير البحر الابراج الصينيه
تنقسم الى 12 برجا تمثل اثني عشر حيوانات
مقبل عم التنين متابعه
احتفالاته سنه الجديده هناك بعض المحرمات
التي لا يفضل القيام بها اولا
ليس او
التخلق قمامه قبل اليوم الخامس لان ذلك
يرمز للتخلص من الحظ السعيد الكلمات ذات
الدلالات السلبيه ممنوعه خلال الاحتفالات
وتشمل الموت والمرض والفقر والالم والفراغ
والقتل والسبب منع النحس او جلب هذه
المفردات لاقاربك كسر الزجاج او السيراميك
ممنوع ايضا لانها تعني قطع الاتصال
بالازدهار والثروه لكن اذا سقط طبق وانكسر
عن طريق الخطا فيمكن لفه في ورق ورميه في
بحيره
صالونات تصفيف الشعر مغلقه خلال الاعياد
وهو من المحرمات اذ ان المقص يقطع الخيط
الواصل بالنجاح والثروه في اوقات الاعياد
يرتاح المديون اذ انه من غير المحبه
المطالبه بسداد الاموال لانها ستجلب الحظ
السيء للدائن يفضل تجنب البكاء وتناول
الادويه لمنع الاصابه بالمرض طوال العام
الا اذا كانت مساله حياه او موت
[موسيقى]
فيديوهات عيدي علي بالصيني العربيه
طلعلهم وحش وحش اسطوري ينفث النار اسمه
نيام وهذا الوحش شو كان يسوي كان يقتل
الحيوانات والناس ويعمل فوضه في القرى
فالناس مو عارفين شو يسوون ضد على الوحش
فاكتشفه ان هذا الوحش يخاف من اللون
الاحمر ويخاف من الاصوات العاليه ويخاف من
النور
[موسيقى]
يولعون العاب الناريه ويعلقون اللوحات
الحمراء والفوانيس الحمر شو حتى يخوفون
الوحش يعني ومن هنا بدات اسطوره او قصه
راس السنه
الحيوانات الله
لكل سنه
الدائره دائره السنه او قصدي
الكلندر عباره عن 12 سنه
فكل سنه ترمز له حيوان معين وكل حيوان له
صفات معينه الارنب معروف ان السريع ااه
ويقولون انه يفكر ببطء بحيث انه ياخذ
القرار الصحيح فالارنب يعتبر من السنوات
التي انتهجها الصينيون»
في راس السنه همم يعتبر من اهم المهرجانات
اللي عندهم او همم احتفال براس السنه فكل
الصينين لازم يتجمعون مع بعض في راس السنه
حتى لو كانوا مو موجودين في قصدي في دول
مختلفه يتجمعون كائله
اجتماع العام العائله هذا الشيء ضروري عند
الصينيين واا طبعا الصينيين لازم ياكلون
على طاوله مدوره
طاوله مدوره بحيث انه اذا حطوا الاكل
الواحد يقدر يوصل لاي اكله
والغريب الصينيين عنده ابعاده شبيهه
بالعربي هو المسلمين العيديه
عندهم ظرف احمر
اسمهم يعني احمر او يعني ظرف
فالكبار شو يسوون يحطونه فلوس في همم
الظرف يوزعون على الاطفال مثل العيديه
وهذا يعتبر
سنوات القادمه
بدي كمان اسالك لانه في كثير امور بتنحكى
انه هل فعلا حساب عمر الانسان وفق التقويم
الصيني والابراج انه احنا اكبر سنه من
عمرنا الحالي يعني ببلش عمر الانسان من
بطن امه ينحسب سنه
[ضحك]
التقليد مستمر
انا شخصيا كمسلمه احتفل بس مهما كان لازم
اجمع العائله فانا انا انا اسوي مثلا
حسابيه
طيب واليوم قال بيقولوا لك بما انه لغه
بما انه عامل ارنب بعرف انه في كثير
اساطير بتنحكى عشان هيك نحن عم نسال هل
فعلا انه الارنب هو عامل حذفه بالتالي
كمان الاقتصاد الصيني انه العلاقه قال
بالاقتصاد الصيني انه راح يكون جيد وفعال
هذه السنه
وسريعون الافضل فراح نشوف خلال موضوع
السنه هذه باذن الله
انه البرج الارنب يعني فيه سرعه في حظ
بالضبط